- [Narrator] The House
Ways and Means Committee
voted along party lines
Tuesday to make six years
of former President Donald
Trump's tax returns public.
- There being 24 ayes and 16 nos,
the motion to submit the
committee report to the House
is agreed to and the documents are ordered
reported to the House.
- [Narrator] Trump didn't
voluntarily release
his tax returns and had fought in court
to block the Internal Revenue Service
from handing them over.
The IRS hasn't completed
the Trumps' audits
for any of those years.
Documents released by the Committee
show Donald Trump and Melania
Trump reported negative income
in four of the six years
from 2015 through 2020.
For 2018 and 2019, the Trumps reported
adjusted gross income of 24.3 million
and 4.4 million respectively.
All years combined, documents show
their adjusted gross income
was negative $53.2 million
during that period.
The Trumps paid some form
of federal taxes every year,
but reported income tax
liability of $750 or less
in three of those six years.
A spokesman for Trump on Tuesday night
called approving the release
of the tax returns a, quote,
"unprecedented leak by
lame duck Democrats,"
and House Republicans said the action
sets a dangerous precedent.
- After nearly a half a century,
the political enemies list
is back in Washington D.C.,
and we worry this will unleash a cycle
of political retribution in Congress.
- [Narrator] Democrats
said that the full release
was necessary for public transparency.
A full set of Trump's tax documents
was expected to become
public in the coming days.
(dramatic tonal music)